This is my first rodent.
What does it taste like to you?
Tastes like chicken.
[LAUGHS]
Everything that the
American cuisine is today
is because all these different
people and different cultures
contributed to it.
Mm.
Oh, my god.
It's such a flavor explosion.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Everybody knows Thai food.
Nobody knows about Thai people.
There's the dish, and then
there's the hands that
prepare and serve the dish.
[LAUGHTER]
This alone is reason
to come to El Paso.
Mm.
Ah.
That's good, huh?
[LAUGHS]
Burp a little.
Le Thai 2.0, dude.
Padma Thai?
Watch your back.
God damn it.
[LAUGHS]
Food is medicine.
We've all heard that before.
It's much deeper than
just what feeds you.
It's like a
spiritual connection.
The gateway to
another culture often
happens first through food.
OK, Inshallah, as they say.
Inshallah.
If you sit at my table and eat
with me, you'll know who I am.
This is what American
food looks like.
This is the original.
This is real America.
I'm really sorry
you can't eat this.
[PANTING] I always
[BLEEP] do that.